.
>> Tucker: THE SAY ANYTHING,
LITERALLY ANYTHING.
OZ IS RUNNING AGAINST FEDERMAN
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS DOCTOR FOR COMING ON.
AS A NONPENNSYLVANIAN, I LOOK AT
THE RACE AND THINK, YOU'VE NEVER
HELD ELECTIVE OFFICE SEND YOUR
WINNING.
THAT SUGGESTS TO ME THAT
FEDERMAN IS DONE A UNIQUELY BAD
JOB.
WHERE THESE DEMOCRATS COMING IN
AND VOUCHING FOR A GUY WHO CAN'T
EVEN WIN A RACE IN HIS STATE
THAT WHERE'S LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR?
>> I THINK THEY JUST WANT THE
51ST VOTE IN THE SENATE.
THEY DON'T APPRECIATE THAT
FEDERMAN HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
DEFEND HIS RADICAL VIEWS.
THAT'S THE ISSUE IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
THESE EXTREME POSITIONS ARE OUT
OF TOUCH WITH PENNSYLVANIA
VALUES.
HE SAYS FRACKING IS STAYING ON
PENNSYLVANIA.
HE SAYS HE DOESN'T SUPPORT
FRACKING, BUT ON THE DEBATE
STAGE HE KEEPS SAYING THAT HE IS
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF IT.
HE CAN'T RECONCILE IT.
PENNSYLVANIA IS ARE SAYING THAT
WASHINGTON IS GETTING IT WRONG
WITH RADICAL POSITIONS.
I STAND FOR BALANCE.
THE NIGHT OF THE DEBATE,
FEDERMAN RAISED MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN ORDER TO ADVANCE HIS
CAMPAIGN.
HE'S GOTTEN MORE FROM OTHER
SENATE LEADERS RIGHT NOW THAT I
COULD IMAGINE BEING GIVEN.
PLEASE HELP ME FIGHT BACK.
GO TO DR. OZ.COM.
THIS RACE WILL BE DEFINED BY THE
ADS PLAYING ON BOTH SIDES.
I WOULD TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT
FEDERMAN MORE THAN THE LIES
ABOUT ME.
>> Tucker: IT'S UNREAL THAT HE
ATTACKS YOU FOR BEING RICH,
WHICH YOU ARE.
BUT YOU MADE YOUR MONEY.
THIS IS A GUY WHO LIVED OFF HIS
PARENTS UNTIL LATE MIDDLE-AGE,
HE'S NEVER HAD A REAL JOB AND
HE'S GOT RICH CONFUSED.
HE'S AGAINST FRACKING.
WOULD HE THINK ROLE PENNSYLVANIA
HAS?
HOW CAN YOU BE AGAINST FRACKING
IN A STATE THAT NEEDS BRETT
ENERGY REVENUE?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> THAT'S WHY IT'S BEEN
FLIP-FLOPPING.
HE'S TAKING THE STRONG STANCE TO
PROTECT CRIMINALS OVER THE
DESIRES OF THE INNOCENT GREAT
HE'S WANTED TO RELEASE ONE-THIRD
OF ALL PRISONERS GOOD HE ARGUES
IF HE COULD WAVE A MAGIC WAND
HE'D GET RID OF LIFE SENTENCES
FOR FELONY MURDER.
HE TRIED TO PUSH 25 MURDERS OUT
OF JAIL OVER THE DESIRES OF
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PAROLE
BOARD.
BUSINESSES ARE LEAVING
PHILADELPHIA BECAUSE IT'S
DANGEROUS.
THE FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE
VOTED FOR ME UNANIMO